let me let me start by welcoming all are
our first your master students and to
remind you that you're the first week
you got a very nice talk so the global
perspective of integrating many of the
components of what we think of as as
modern public health and last week we
sort of drilled down to focus on the the
modeling piece one small aspect of what
it is that we do in our profession this
week we're going back to the very global
uh although logo in its scope a global
in it in the areas that it covers by
having gaya Heller who currently works
for the Assistant Commissioner for
bureau of alcohol and drug abuse
prevention city of New York and has had
a interesting should I say checkered
career sir in in providing health
services to drug users in New York City
to come and talk with us about sort of
the right practical aspects of public
health some of you may find that you go
into those practical aspects and we
don't teach you that in our school as
you may have figured out we need you all
sorts of curious weird things like SAS
epidemiology but I get some more on the
practical public health aspect I we
asked Dahlia to come and talk about the
work she's been doing for the past
though 13 15 years something like that
what you should also know that she is
currently in school getting her PhD at
City University of New York she tells me
that her defense date is November ninth
so if you see her in panic mode it has
nothing to do with the audience in front
of her definitely with the fact that in
a month and a half she's got to defend a
thesis no you're not panic you're cool
with that yeah okay so Dahlia Heller
from New York thank you Robert
um okay so I'm gonna wean because I
think it will just make it easier for me
up here so actually just context from my
own history is that I walked into this
role as not my current role but my
previous role as a director of a syringe
exchange program in New York City
straight out of an mph and exactly what
Robert said I I had actually over the
course the nine years that I ran the
harm reduction organization people used
to once Noel like jokingly friends
especially say like yes are you using
your mph they taught you that right they
taught you like how to do contractor
work and build a wall so that you could
make offices for case managers they
taught you how to like you know call the
plumber when the bathroom whatever
negotiate like the lease with the
landlord's so it was actually kind of
funny because in a lot of ways I
probably similarly didn't get anything
from an mph that helped me directly in a
very tangible way develop and run an
organization that was doing public
health work and you know to me my
framework was always public health but
it wasn't i wasn't really using on a
day-to-day basis my mph in my current
job working in City Department of Health
clearly I'm actually throwing myself
back into all this old epi stuff and
wishing I had just done like epi two and
three yesterday instead of now whatever
13 years ago or 14 years ago so it's
been interesting so I want to talk i'm
gonna Robert asked me to talk about sort
of the experience of being a community
provider and then moving from being a
community provider into government and
what it looks like doing public health
work in those two environments I don't
know how many of you have thought about
going and doing community-based work
following your mph or have come from
doing community-based work whether here
or internationally who's laughing
oh ok okay go ahead um just let me take
advantage please ok I think I know some
of you I don't need to go ahead but i am
with sierra but also with the Office of
Community Health and for those of you
who are mph students and we'll be doing
a practical I'm one of the people that
you'll be working with I was in public
health practice for 25 years and so I'm
sure I'm going to relate to a lot of
what you have to say value but I think
it's great that you're talking about
okay good I'm glad it's um okay good so
I think that's important really as to if
you're thinking about where you want to
go think about how you can maximize what
what you're going to get out of an mph
to work in a community based environment
because there is not a whole lot but it
it's actually speaking of a practicum I
think that that is one of the few
probably direct opportunities to
actually get your feet wet or start to
think broadly about transferring mph
kind of skills and knowledge into
community based on the ground work so so
with that said just to think about what
what I think about when I think about
where I'm coming from in terms of doing
public health work and what has been a
consistent stream in my work over the
past 12 13 years in this area of HIV
substance use I don't know poverty
homelessness can kind of build on that
sure has been that I'm coming from a
human rights framework and that was not
something that I actually ever thought
very articulated for myself when I
walked into my first job walking out of
the mph which was running the syringe
exchange program but something which was
more of a gut response of why I ended up
working in a syringe exchange program
and now sort of has developed I mean
there's a lot of literature that's come
out in the last ten years i'm sure
you're familiar with on Public Health
and Human Rights and Health and Human
Rights and there's been instant
suits that have developed around this
idea and there's a lot more
international focus on this issue but it
wasn't so common in the mid-90s I'd say
and you know it was sort of but of
course why do you go into public health
probably a lot of the reason why you go
into public health is because you do
believe in health is a human right and
broadly public health right so that's
sort of the framework for how I approach
the work I do or how I consistently
approached wherever I am whatever I'm
doing how I think about public health is
public health is a human right so within
that framework um then I kind of when I
quickly wrote what was I going to talk
about or what was the kind of theme of
my top going to be I use the word power
and maybe it was like late at night and
I was about to go on vacation I just
handed in my dissertation so may I
wasn't really I don't know why I got
caught up in this idea of power but I
guess partly because people think of
government is having a lot of power and
I but I've ended up in this government
official position sort of quite
accidentally and the idea it's laughable
to me in a lot of ways I guess the idea
that i have power now because i miss a
lot of the power that I feel like I
actually did have when I was working in
the community and so I want to talk
about what i mean by that when i talk
about power i mean it certainly there
are kind of very traditional ways of
understanding the power that I maybe
have now but frankly you know there was
a lot the power that comes from
community-based work is and that you
develop and can really hone in
community-based work to move a human
rights framework for public health is
pretty significant so that's sort of
going to be the general theme of what I
talk about you know power in a very
broad kind of sense so the way I'm going
to talk through this is really
chronological I'll tell you about my
experience running an organization and
then moving from there to work in
governments and what that transition is
like this is probably a different kind
of talk I think from what you'd normally
have in these talks am I correct right
there more kind of research focused
these talks easily so I guess Hut have
been maybe this will help me a little
bit how many of you have ever done
communities based works like I don't
know any kind of human service work or
Peace Corps even I think would count and
whatever oh so a lot of you and how many
of you have thought that you might go
back and do more of that after your mph
or do that after your mph if you haven't
done it before a few of you okay um so
and how many of you are interested in
doing research after your mph more ng
like research is community-based
research right I mean probably you're
here and how many of you have thought
you would go into government okay a lot
of views who all right so that gives me
a good sense of they're all sort of the
same thing actually so it's just the
perspective you're in right and it's
quite interesting to think about how you
move that perspective around so I
started I had the good fortune really of
tripping over an individual who was a
board member of a syringe exchange
program that was looking for a director
just as I was finishing my mph at the
time I was working for the drug policy
foundation which no longer exists is now
sort of loosely the drug policy Alliance
does a lot less funding and were his
focus more on advocacy and policy work
but what was interesting is the reason I
was working at the drug policy
foundation was not because I was
particularly interested in drug policy
per se but because when I had gone back
to school to zoom my masters in public
health I had been doing maternal child
health work in the community and that
had always been my focus in my interest
in where I was going of course that
meant I was tripping up against HIV
Sachs work drug use lots of these issues
but I was always very focused on
maternal child help women and children
that's where I was
where my interest was and I needed a job
while I was going to school and I got
this opportunity i saw this job posting
to work at a foundation and I'd always
thought we want to go and run a program
that was sort of had developed to be
something I was interested in doing but
it works in programs and I felt like
well I understand how to set up a
program ever understand how to design
service delivery the thing is mysterious
is Grant's how do you get grants what is
a grant how do you write a grant how do
you know what grants are out there what
is a grant and so I thought well you
know let me just see what's out there
says I'm looking around this foundation
job and it's drug policy foundation so I
interviewed and I got the job and I'm
from Toronto Canada originally but this
was all in New York and so I go to this
interview and I find out in the
interview that syringe exchange a needle
exchange you know is a really hot potato
in the United States I had was not aware
of this I had actually worked with women
in the Bronx who were injectors hadn't
really crossed my mind about where they
were getting syringes actually because I
just sort of where I grew up in Toronto
the first needle exchange program opened
down the block from my high school when
I was 14 my best friend's mom and her
boyfriend volunteered there it was a
normal right didn't really blink yeah
this needle exchange program whatever so
I go to this interview and I find out
that needle exchange is really hot weird
thing and not weird but they like very
hot and controversial for the United
States still and this was like 95 96 um
so anyway I felt like I had sort of a
perspective on it just having kind of
been in the middle of rounded not really
paying attention to it and of course it
was you know I was gonna learn about
grants so I was interested in the job so
I got the job and that's where I worked
through my Master's so I developed this
understanding of harm reduction how many
of you have heard of harm reduction or
know what harm reduction is does
somebody feel like they could define
what harm reduction is
or if you're eating it's okay mouths
[ __ ] yeah I go ahead lower lower access
to many things that can come for me
maybe like maybe like gluten so ever
prevent a so like to prevent access to
things that could be harmful to you yeah
or exposure prevent exposure to things
would be harmful to you yeah could be
but then you could say for example like
drug interdiction is harm reduction
right maybe because the goal is to
prevent drug from being available to
somebody it's not usually what we think
of as harm reduction though sanguine
what else want to take a stab of what
that go ahead yeah right so it's sort of
taking what is there right now so what
is the situation right now and how can
we address the situation right now to
reduce the harms associated potential
harms associated with that situation
right so but to me there's a
philosophical kind of underpinning to
that whole approach which is really
based in human rights again right
because it's not about here's this
situation here the way it is right now
and oh well clearly you need to change
right so you're gonna go over here now
and actually I'm gonna fold you up like
that and I'm going to turn you inside
out and I'm gonna turn you into the
human being I want you to be human
beings are kind of complex right i mean
we're not really that easy to change or
and you know we may even say we want to
change but you know there's like another
part of our brain that we are not
listening to when we say we want to
change that's not ready to change yet so
to me harm reduction is really a
philosophy that places the power to for
making decisions in the person who's
maybe call receiving the service or and
you know participating in the service
really is the way I've always preferred
to think about it because it's it's
really that individual has to be at the
center of everything right so I mean a
very classic harm reduction is syringe
exchange and that's what we've always
kind of that's we often talk about and
talk about harm reduction it's kind of a
euphemism for syringe exchange a lot of
the time but more broadly I like to
think about it is like a theoretical
approach that's really a human rights
approach particularly to dealing with
issues of substance use in human beings
so harm reduction kind of made sense to
me learning about harm reduction while I
was working at this foundation harm
reduction syringe exchange Anna's like
oh yeah of course that's like the way I
would approach working with people
that's kind of the way I've approached
working with people the woman using
drugs pregnant woman eight eight months
pregnant using drugs nine kids in foster
care sex worker wants to keep this baby
so I didn't like harangue her about her
drug use the developing fetus in her
body the nine kids that she'd already
lost why she was doing sex work and
could instead whatever whatever and said
I said well what do you want to do I
want to keep the baby okay you want to
keep the baby so what do we need need to
get you into treatment okay so we got to
find treatment for a pregnant woman in
New York City you know so I mean it was
it was a partnership right and I mean
that's sort of serve it wasn't that you
know she had said I want to keep using
drugs then it would have been okay so
how are we going to think about the baby
developing inside of you want to keep
you know I mean I guess does that make
sense sort of just it's you know it's an
individual's decision because at the end
of the day it's always going to be their
decision you know people get drug people
people get access to drugs in jail we
know that you can't prevent people from
using drugs like I could have locked her
in a room if she wanted to get high she
probably would have found out a way to
get higher so you brought have hurt
herself in the process of trying to find
a way to get high it's not about
controlling people and I think that's
very important it's a human rights of
too especially working with people who
are dealing with issues around drug and
alcohol use so I got this job because
this I tripped over this board member
who was an adjunct professor Columbia
who happened to be on the board of the
syringe exchange whose founder had
suffered an untimely death he overdosed
and died after founding a syringe
exchange program in the Bronx and he had
just really pulled together the skeleton
of a program he had a board he had a
fiscal conduit he was a photographer
kind of an artist who made a name for
himself and had a lot of friends in the
art world had raised some money through
them so we've gotta know like twenty
five thousand dollars spent some of that
money on buying a minivan and st. Louis
and driving it back to the Bronx so he
had a minivan there was a really old
computer that was still like an ms-dos I
remember that I inherited so and we were
in the donated space in the basement of
a church and it was me and this core of
volunteers that had been very committed
to him that were still around and then
the board had been sort of in their
spare time because they all worked
somewhere else organizing the volunteers
and coordinating them and continuing to
go out and do syringe exchange because
the one really key thing was that he had
managed to get a waiver authorizing this
program to do syringe exchange in New
York State so that was the very precious
thing that the board did not want to
give up he had founded he'd done all
this work to get this waiver to be
authorized to give out syringes to
injecting drug users and that was enough
to keep them going searching for a
director for a year and a half and then
I walked in so I was there for nine
years in this position running this
organization which sort of thanks to my
very small exposure to Foundation grant
world somehow I wrote my first
government grant a couple of months into
the job and got it and like quadrupled
the agency's budget
it and then things just went and you
know I kind of rushed to keep up with
myself and to what was happening around
us so the organization grew and you
knows became this multi-service harm
reduction organization so I guess to
think about what was the power that
thinking about power in that role or in
that space right running a
community-based organization doing
community-based work we were working
with homeless injecting drug users
people living with hiv/aids and
everybody was using some kind of drug or
another at some point in out so there
was a lot of crack use as well as a lot
of injecting drug use and not everybody
was an injector so because injectors
don't just hang out with injectors just
like right blondes don't just hang out
with blondes or whatever mean people are
people so then we weren't like saying
well we don't have anything for you
because you don't stick needles in your
arms so you just wait at the door and
we'll take care of your friends and that
wasn't you know that wasn't that's not
really a human rights approach not
really what would feel right in my gut
so it's not how we worked so that kind
of to say that walking into this and you
know immediately you're dealing with
issues of homelessness issues of
injecting drug use issues of their form
access to healthcare misused of
untreated mental illness and you're
seeing what people are not getting and
you're trying to advocate for them to
get these things that you see clearly
that they need and that there are
systems of service available in systems
of care available to deal with and those
systems aren't accepting these people
and they're not working with you so it's
very it's almost impossible not to start
doing advocacy right because you're
individually doing advocacy for people
you're working with every day and you're
seeing actually that there's sort of a
systemic barrier to getting people what
they need so you you know I started I
got involved immediately really in
housing
advocacy and advocacy for homeless
active drug users because they were
really getting shunned by the shelter
system as far as I could see also I mean
they were worse to the worst it was
better for them to live on the street
and then you know also of course around
syringe exchange and then needs to
expand syringe exchange and then active
drug users and medical care especially
also and like access to good health care
for people who continue to use drugs so
you know that kind of what I was doing
was exposing the problem I knew that I
wasn't going to be able to change your
doing advocacy on the outside right what
you're not actually ever going to change
something yourself because you need
legislation to change or you need a
policy to change what you're trying to
do is expose a problem to raise
attention to a problem to bring
attention to that problem these public
health issues and to either humiliate if
that's what it takes an elected official
government official into recognizing the
problem and changing it addressing it or
actually to you know build partnership
with them because they say oh we didn't
know that that was that's the problem
wow that's a problem oh you're right and
we could just change like that and work
together draft legislation and change
the problem I mean and it can happen
both ways right and it did happen both
ways I think I mean we had some you have
a question um feel free to interrupt me
though because I'm just going to keep
blabbering and I'm gonna have to shut up
at one so I'll try to like move through
this but yeah go ahead
walking is against oscillating syringe
programs and trend exchange programs
right okay so what is ok so we recognize
the benefits right we've seen we know
that you know if people given access to
a sterile syringe and they're an
injection drug user they're more likely
to use a sterile syringe for multiple
reasons including that it's better to
have a new needle with a clean point and
a clean syringe better also and
therefore they're not going to be forced
into a situation where they have to
borrow or you know come their friend has
to borrow from them a syringe right so
we're reducing blood-borne transmission
of disease why is it so controversial
well ok so we have a history in this
country of approaching problems of drug
use with remembered just say no right I
mean maybe you don't remember just say
no but just say no right was Nancy Nancy
Reagan is sort of considered of coins
adder you know that was her slogan
around in the 80s and the idea that
syringe exchange is giving somebody a
tool to use drugs so it seems that you
are therefore then condoning the drug
use because you're giving somebody the
tool to use the drugs if you didn't give
them the tool to use the drugs then
everything would be okay right well yeah
if you look at the world you know if you
operate in a vacuum but everything
wouldn't be okay because then we'd have
more HIV Hep C you know and untreated
you know soft tissue infections etc in
that population and you know for
infectious disease you know like
especially HIV more broadly in the
community of which those individuals are
part of right so when you see I think
the idea is are you approaching the
issue from a public health perspective
or are you poaching it from a I don't
like to use the
werd more morality but it is a I don't
know how well I mean morale morality
doesn't have to be a bad thing so I
don't mean that and you know because I
think morals can be good to know and I
mean that in the I mean that in the best
way but I think sometimes but I do but
in this case I mean morality like
there's a right and wrong and it is
wrong to use drugs and if you give
somebody needles you're promoting or
supporting or encouraging their
continued drug use and you may in fact
also be exposing other people to the
idea wow I could inject drugs too
because I can get needles there never
mind that you have to go and get the
drugs you have to want to use the drugs
you have to then know how to and I know
there's all these other things and
people don't just choose to inject drugs
because it seems like a fabulous idea
something I want to wake up tomorrow and
start doing there's a whole lot else
that goes into how and why people
initiate drug use people continue drug
use because experimentation is sort of
like a human I think we wouldn't have
you know we wouldn't be in this building
you know with like four walls and a
ceiling and electricity if human beings
hadn't been experimenting for a few
millennia but you know whether people
continue using drugs there's a whole lot
of other reasons why so but the backlash
or that you know why it's so
controversial in this country is because
this country has a taken a very strong
stance particularly over the last 30 40
years but actually I mean frankly you
know increasingly over the last hundred
years that drug used all drug use is bad
they tried it with alcohol and it didn't
you know prohibition really kind of blew
things out of the water so they had to
like find they had to start promoting
temperance instead of prohibition right
but with drugs we've managed to escalate
a war on drugs so that's I don't know if
I answered your question in a very
long-winded way but is that so
so power in the community so in addition
to doing advocacy myself and as I
developed or got more funding and
getting staff involved in doing advocacy
and obviously working with other
community providers doing advocacy and
advocates and researchers because we
need the data that research develops
becomes a lot of the time the basis for
the argument that we're going to go you
know in addition to pointing to the five
decrepit buildings that the city's
placing homeless people with aids in or
whatever or you know bringing ten people
who are going to testify it's also very
helpful to say and this famous
epidemiologist at yale university
published his paper that shows that it
right and you know research science you
know also speaks of course still not to
morality a lot of the time science and
morality sometimes like still or not you
know morality is not hearing science but
again because they're coming from
different perspectives of what's
important so the part of building
service delivery then also became coming
in contact with people and rather than
just being to me a social service
organization which would have been very
humdrum and like in the bronx says like
the community board would tell you in
the South Bronx the community is
saturated the biggest business in the
Bronx is social services and healthcare
far and away and you know and it's the
poorest congressional district in the
country so I don't know whatever but you
know the politicians are always in close
relationships with the nonprofit
executive directors and you know the
leadership at local community health
centers and whatever that is the
business there's efforts to change and
like as the Bronx continues to
revitalize it's certainly not the Bronx
it was in the 80s I've by and far you
know it's it's changed enormously
especially on the surface but there is
still underneath there
are still a lot of these issues these
public health issues that are still need
to be addressed and so if we could have
been another social service agency in
the Bronx and I really didn't uh I don't
think that I didn't feel like that was
necessary we could just give out needles
then and close our doors and people were
getting their mental illness untreated
well fine I know there's five mental
health clinics in the borough just go to
one of them are they won't see you
whatever I you know that's there you
know I can't really help you I can't I
don't have mental health services here
well the truth is after a while right I
mean if you're coming from a human
rights perspective you're not gonna
watch and run up against these system
walls and not try to resolve them than
yourself so in addition to going and
screaming at people and trying to get
policies changed and trying to get
service systems to treat people like
human beings you also may be going to
seek some funding to like higher I don't
know psychiatrist eight hours a week so
that you know God at least people can
get psych evals here and got medication
here if you can find a psychiatrist
who's willing to work with active drug
users in a drop-in center in the South
Bronx right and has liability insurance
and you know whatever to be able to
prescribe and in that setting etc and so
because they can't bill right because
you don't carry your billing ability
around with you there's whole rules
around billing blah blah blah so but
that's what I did so you know is that
you can't just we couldn't just not
provide services to people that we're
not getting those services if we're
really trying to help people and you
know how people live right and not die I
mean it's one thing to give somebody a
clean needle but that's not the
beginning and the end of it there's the
clean needle and the conversation and
then there's the clean needle and the
conversation and the education and then
there's the clean needle in the
conversation in the education and the
like though also the listening in the
course of that of like oh and you need
this right and you go back to the
cardboard box in the park five blocks
away every night and you go there
because the shelter will let you bring
the needles in
in and or your partner got killed in the
shelter three years ago and you don't
ever want to go back there or because
you know you feel like it's you know
more violent than the little place
you've carved out for yourself in the
park or so you know you need housing so
how come you know so we developed
services and as you develop services
will you help people actually improve
their lives right because now they're
actually able to see a doctor and got
that you know bad abscess on their leg
actually dealt with and maybe they end
up having to get some surgery for it but
you know now it's getting better and
they're feeling good it's getting better
in there they're getting it dealt with
instead of carrying this festering up
and wound around in their leg all the
time and you know what now you've gotten
them into a supportive housing place and
you can actually there's somewhere they
can go and sleep at night this doesn't
have to be the cardboard box in the park
and so that their lives have changed and
there's also then you know an
opportunity for them to have a voice in
talking about their own experience if
they want right so what I also always
emphasized was sort of this kind of
participatory approach not just to
services so it's not just about you know
I'm the center of service i'm the one
who's needing services but I'm you know
where I'm defining those services but
it's also about my voice right and what
my voice can you know say to the world
so and I think that there's a lot I mean
a lot of the time you walk the line I
guess with advocacy and involving
participants of services in advocacy
with and pardon the expression but like
pimping people quite frankly right and I
think it's very important as the service
provider to be conscious that you hold
power you're the one that holds you know
whether it's just the keys to the nice
doctor or the keys to that great like
housing that you're going to get me or
whatever so that means when I say hey
we're trying to fill a bus to go to
albany or to go to DC whatever do you
feel like I make
you do that because I might be holding
that housing placement over your head
this is like a very important kind of
for me constantly important scale to
weigh and to kind of avoid as much as
possible to give people as much power
and knowledge themselves to understand
well what's going on so what's going on
in DC right now so we would do like at
least monthly meetings where it actually
talked about policy issues that were
affecting people so people started to
get a very clear idea of like what is
the Ryan White Care Act for example or I
mean things are always bubbling up right
so different things would go on and we
talking about them and or what is HOPWA
housing opportunities for people with
AIDS or what's going on with AIDS
housing in this country or what's going
on with housing for active drug users
and what are the opportunities out there
so really educating people so that they
feel like they have an understanding
it's not it's now I'm in a context right
like now it's not now I see that like my
experiences we're part of a bigger
picture and that made a huge difference
because it's the investment then of the
people who are receiving services in the
space actually becomes the space the
space is theirs and you know designing
you know architecture you know if you're
building you know we I had the
opportunity to develop space in the
course of my job and to be able to kind
of design the space so that it was open
enough so that there was like the
ownership just you felt like if you were
receiving services there you weren't
sitting behind bulletproof glass and you
know three uncomfortable sofa chairs
waiting for your name to be called you
sort of had the run of the place you
know because of the way that it was
built so it was sort of in there's like
the food place upstairs and over there
is like the cafe area and over here the
cuts is an inter interspersed with
offices providing services and then
doing pure education and in all of this
would be a very structured approach to
just getting people not only to learn
out learn about the bigger issues but
also to become leaders themselves in
their communities which again is just
tapping into peoples natural instincts
so go ahead you have a question social
behavior no none it was helpful to be
able to read research so I could use it
to do policy advocacy stuff it was
helpful to be able to write you know
because it's always helpful to be able
to write to write a grant and maybe I
can't honestly remember anymore there
were mph courses around designing
services like designing programs but if
there are that that's kind of helpful to
think about but there isn't really a lot
i think is there NM page curriculum that
practicums are probably the way to go
there is okay I don't have a penchant
for service there are go ahead I think
there's quite a few hours to days
actually there's a lot of good courses
in the School of Public Health trace
dozen interventions course or a couple
of practical courses Debbie Humphrey
says the community practice course we
work as a group of students on a real
project infusion behaving or an area of
community so I think there are lots of
opportunities and i would say Dahlia
that in my experience I actually
ultimately used all of that knowledge in
my practice in one way or another so I
did think it was a very practical degree
which is what an mph is supposed to be
it is a very practical degree yeah I
would say that I honestly Halak
perspective in some ways because it was
so long ago that I don't yeah but I'm
yeah and I sort of was hurtling for it
okay go ahead yeah you've question oh
yeah I was wondering if you found it
difficult to like start conversations
with that like terms
because I know like if I go to the
dentist I hate going to the dentist just
because they like start telling me like
you need to floss you need to do this
like because they're telling you what to
do yeah you start to have conversations
with these people who are using did that
I kind of turn them away a little bit or
are they like really open to like
talking to you about like what like
maybe why they started using her have
you been to like different dentists like
I went to either dentist I grew up where
I'm serious dude different dentist a
different bedside manner right i went to
a dentist the dentist i grew up with was
horrible I mean he knew I was like into
political things so he would like stick
his hands in my mouth and then start
like railing off about stuff that I
didn't agree with right and you know and
making fun of my clothes and whatever
and then hurting me all at the same time
and like you know I was like I left home
and I thought I'm never going there
again like and I actually found a
dentist in New York who I love which is
shocking because who loves going to the
dentist but I love him because he
doesn't tell me to floss like he doesn't
tell me you know okay so i don't always
floss he doesn't he doesn't go after me
for not always flossing instead he
points out what's going on in my mouth
right and explains like how that happens
and explains how that could be different
so he is empowering me with information
instead of just her banging me you know
what I mean that I mean does that make
sense oh yeah it's how you engage people
right and again it's hot your dentist
who's telling you to you should do this
you should do this you should do this
he's not really putting you at the
center like how does he know you live in
a place where you can floss every night
like or whatever you know what I me and
hat he's not even like finding out about
you he's telling you what to do like
he's treating you like just like the
next guy and now move along right
instead of putting you at the center of
the picture and like hearing from you
and teaching you something and then
maybe you want to get into that
conversation on maybe he'll see you're
like whatever you know mad at you fine
you told me about my gum disease and I'm
still getting up and leaving I don't
talk about how to floss so um all right
so i guess i don't i don't know i'm like
wandering around this conversation a
little bit but just to finish talking
about community-based services i mean
that i just think that there's a lot of
power and being able to expose problems
and to demonstrate solutions to those
problems and there's a lot more power
and community to be able to do that
frankly than in government because you
the lift is a lot less you're in control
right you're you can be creative and
innovative in this very particular space
but the reason I left running a
community-based organization was because
it's also very difficult you always also
maintains feel it's very difficult I
mean it's just your there's a lot of
it's a recipe for burnout if you're not
if you don't know how to manage the work
that will never end and I think prize
used to say that I wasn't emotionally
mature enough for the job that was like
my I whatever I started when I was 24
and ain't no just sort of like it just
kind of ran away from me like I said so
it grew and it was successful and it's
still there fortunately and you know
it's serving lots of people and it's
always popping I just talked to somebody
yesterday who said they'd been there the
day before and they were like whew now I
had a meeting participant fiberboard and
they got an agenda and they want us to
work on this advocacy and this advocacy
in this advocacy we were talking about
and I was like yeah and isn't it crazy
there's like a hundred people in the
drop-in center all the time like I would
have to go to the bathroom and I would
not leave my office to go to the
bathroom because I knew take me 45
minutes to go to the bathroom and back
because I would stop and talk to 15
people in the course of it because of
the way I designed the space it was all
very open and we're all really relating
all the time so anyway in that
exhaustion and you know knowing that I
was ready for a change and sort of this
opportunity showed up to go and work at
the Department of Health and Mental
Hygiene in New York City
and very quickly because I'm not going
to go into that but i would say that in
I've had a particular experience I don't
think working in all any government is
the same necessarily a lot of it depends
on the leadership at the you know I have
the good fortune of working in a health
department that although he's no longer
there now Tom Frieden really overhauled
the entire health department in New York
City after walking in there in 2002
built a huge division of epidemiology
which frankly hardly existed before just
on it's a standalone on its own to do
epi fur on all public health issues for
the city really and really kind of
developed the work in a very proactive
way for the department and so to work in
that environment where you know and I
suppose more leavin or larger we have a
mayor who's in doubt a public health
school really believes in public health
and then it's a it's also very the mayor
is very data-driven and the health
department's very data-driven
evidence-based and so it's sort of a
great pleasure to work in that
environment it could be a very highly
politicized horrible environment so for
example for syringe exchange it could be
as it was under our previous mayor who
shall go unnamed in New York City but
who actually decided methadone was a bad
thing and started shutting down
methadone programs at one point during
his tenure as mayor and I can't even
imagine working in a health department
when he was the mayor so I think I
wouldn't you know advocate working in
government in general ever because it
entirely depends on the political
environment at the time and then
resources or the other issue but I think
you can make do with little I think you
can always make do with little because
once you work in government you have
accessed just by that's where power
comes in right that's like the what we
think of as power in government is like
because I can call somebody up and say
I'm
so calling from trauma health mental
hygiene and I still laugh about it I'm
so shocked people call me back like like
that I never people never called me back
before like there's a whole thing they
would pick up the phone they weren't
gonna call me back I'm hi my name is
Dahlia ha i'm the executive directors
this syringe exchange program in the
bogs whatever they're like what I don't
know he is a delete that message but now
I'm like I get a call back like within a
day and it's I mean it's ridiculous
really that that's the way the world is
and that's the way we treat each other
as human beings but it's the truth so
that's power clearly i mean this power
and name right so but yeah and i think
theoretically there's power because we
could not only expose problems with you
know our hands all over lots of data and
i will savor just to kind of close this
out i mean the thing that's been most
enjoyable for me walking into the city
Department of Health and Mental Hygiene
is that in new york city government has
not taken a very leadership much of a
leadership role around substance use and
issues of substance use since the 70s
since the fiscal crisis in new york city
at that time the city basically was even
running sort some like methadone
services detox programs themselves and
handed them off to the state handed off
all the responsibility for licensing
programs etc so we have a public
hospital system that operates separate
from the department it's not part of the
department and they certainly have drug
treatment programs within their within
their service system throughout the
facilities but they don't and they had a
needle exchange short-lived didn't
really work out they had trouble
figuring out how to embrace it in their
hospital but they made an effort which
was good but um but we certainly as
government have either in a particularly
in a policy sort of role or developing
programs we don't have very much of a
history around substance use dated some
studies anything so that's been actually
really joyful is that I walked into a
job where there wasn't much and I was
able to start
are pushing and creating and developing
and I had a you know we've had a
commissioner now we have another
commissioner who sees these is very
important issues that need to be at the
fore we talk about the actual leading
causes of death this idea that you know
you have to move upstream from the
cardiovascular disease and the cancer to
talk about well how did people develop
those diseases and alcohol and drug use
you know figure large in a lot of
premature deaths and so that's sort of
the framework now especially our new
commissioners using to talk about why
we're focused on the initiatives were
focused on as a department and
fortunately alcohol and drugs are large
in that so I guess that's that I guess
that that would be my final comment on
power in government is you know it's not
only the political environment it's also
the buy-in of the leadership for the
particular issue that you're working on
there so because for example you know we
could have not had by in on around
issues of drug use to dealing with
issues of drug user could have been
focused on I don't know something else
tobacco or something we did a lot of
tobacco work already that's nice but um
so yeah it's made a big difference to
have buying of leadership of the health
department itself to be able to raise
the lens on a lot of issues and build
reports put out reports put out
educational literature have the part
Minh take positions on issues that
previously would have just passed it by
etc so I guess along in the short of my
message is that there is a lot there's
ways to find power and to do health
health as a human rights kind of work
out there and I think from an mph you're
probably in any in any do any direction
that you go in you're going to be kind
of thinking about well how am I going to
get this heard what am I trying to
do and then how am I going to get it
heard who's my audience how did I want
them to hear me and I guess I would sort
of advocate that the there's a lot to be
learned from working on the ground and
doing community-based work actually mph
is bring an enormous value to
community-based work because of the
public health perspective I would often
be asked if I had an MSW for example and
I don't I have no understanding i still
don't i've worked with lots of social
workers I totally needed social workers
you know to fill some rules in her in
the organization that Iran but i am not
trained as a social worker and I'm
trained as a public health practitioner
and to me that's what community-based
work has was has been and it's sort of
the experience I carry into government
and it's one o'clock so I did it thanks